another example of how different the
world is the xfl which was struggling in
recent weeks and xfl truthers get upset
when we point out how the ratings were
down and attendance was down and and
look it was only going to get worse
conference tournaments this weekend for
the ncaa would have taken a bite out of
the ratings march madness the following
three weekends i think reality was going
to set in for the xfl until reality
really set in for all of us in the xfl
suspended operations what do you think
mds is next for the xfl they're
capitalized into 2021. now vince mcmahon
can roll out of bed any given day and
say i'm done throwing good money after
bad we can't rule that out but what do
you think happens next
i believe it will come back for the 2021
season
i think vince mcmahon enjoys doing this
you know he's a guy in his 70s with
billions of dollars he just wants to do
what he enjoys doing with his money and
one of the things he enjoys doing is
running a football league so i think it
will be back i think that they will try
to
learn some lessons about making the
league more exciting the style of play
more exciting i think that although some
of their rules were good uh it didn't
really translate to all that exciting a
brand of football and i think that
they're gonna have to rethink a lot of
that i think a lot of the coaches will
change and they'll try to get coaches
who run more innovative offenses and try
to make it more exciting that way
um i think they may move into smaller
stadiums because they realize how hard
it is to fill an nfl-sized stadium so
there there will be changes but i think
vince mcmahon wants to do this and has
the money the cash on hand that he can
do it so i would expect that we will see
the xfl again next year
yeah i agree with you and i think next
year really becomes the test case for
whether or not it's going to work and
look they were still drawing a decent
number of eyeballs on tv even though the
numbers were dropping this past
weekend's ratings were the lowest yet
they had done well from an attendance
standpoint in st louis and seattle i
think they need to move the la team to
san diego and the new york team to
oakland frankly because that concept of
being a
a scorned nfl city worked in st louis
they really need though to think about
the places they can put these teams
where it will resonate with the fan base
and i think it makes a ton of sense to
be in cities that don't have nfl teams
one of the eight teams is in a non-nfl
city and that's st louis and you know i
i think you try to find a city that is
big enough
that you believe will support you san
antonio why they got teams in houston
and dallas so they aren't going to put
one in san antonio but why not put one
of those two teams in san antonio
instead if you find a city that can
rally around a team that doesn't have
anything to otherwise rally around
that's how you get people to come out
it's that simple if they're going to cap
attendance around 20 25 000 because if
they play in these big arenas they're
only going to play in the lower bowl or
only seat people in the lower bowl then
then look for places like that where you
can get 25 to 30 000 on a regular basis
especially since it looks a lot better
on tv and i enjoyed the game and there
were things about it that i liked i mean
people think oh you hate the nf the xfl
so just because i'm pointing out the
things that aren't necessarily positive
doesn't mean i hate the xfl i watched it
every weekend it's football and it's on
tv i love the kickoff i like the
creativity of the extra point i have
ideas for making that better we never
got to see an overtime game
unfortunately because they took our idea
for the overtime two-point conversion
shootout but uh yeah i i i hope it does
well
i've been skeptical though i don't want
to fall in love with it and have it go
away and i'm still skeptical to be back
next year but i hope it will be
and uh you know we'll see
we'll see if they can attract some star
players we'll see if they have a plan
for keeping star players you know pj
walker one of the guys that's likely to
be gone for the nfl will he be back in
the xfl next year we'll see
but but i agree with you it'll be back
and i think next year
the pressure will be on to really
establish a foothold and maintain it and
next year we'll find out whether or not
the xfl can hold its own against uh
the the college basketball tournaments
that were going to suck away a lot of
their audience
yeah and you know the one other thing i
would like to see the xfl do is
something they they talked about doing
and then didn't really do
um which is
sign college freshmen and sophomores who
aren't eligible for the nfl draft and
i don't think they'll ever
be able to offer the kind of money that
a trevor lawrence would take because he
knows hey i'm a year away from getting
tens of millions in the nfl but you know
go go to a wide receiver who made some
big plays in a bowl game who's a
freshman or sophomore and say hey we'll
sign you to a hundred thousand dollars
right now
and make it crystal clear in your
contract that as soon as your nfl draft
eligible you owe us nothing you can
still go to the nfl but we'll pay you a
lot more money than you're making in
college
and i think that would be an interesting
experiment
for
whether they could sign some of the the
second tier not not the guys who are
sure they're going to be first-round
picks in a year but some of the guys who
look like maybe mid-round picks who are
freshmen and sophomores and approach
them about playing in the xfl for a year
or two i think that would be a really
interesting way
for the xfl to position itself as the
developmental league and as a league
that got some guys who we've seen before
oh yeah i remember watching the orange
bowl and score seeing that guy score two
touchdowns that's a reason for me to
tune into an xfl game
well and the i i think that that it's
not a coincidence that once the xfl got
a tv contract with abc and espn we
stopped hearing so much chatter about
them possibly signing college football
players because college football
instantly will put a lot of pressure on
abc and espn for its partnership with
the xfl and and that's why i think it's
not going to happen uh if if the xfl
hadn't and fox is leveraged as well with
college football i think if you're going
to have tv partnerships with networks
that have partnerships with college
football you've got to keep your hands
off of college football players and i
think that's that's one of the reasons
why they didn't offer um a trevor
lawrence 10 million dollars for 10 xfl
games which i think would have been a
small price to pay to guarantee intense
interest in your sport and if you're
trevor lawrence how do you say no to 10
million dollars when you're getting zero
dollars and zero cents plus benefits
babe from uh clemson
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports